in my life am i laughs everybody I
believe I believe we are konnichiwa
mina-san how's the goin I'm doing
another 360p merch stream because it
just dropped some new merch God Church
me Adam it's too old
it stole I still have bad internet so
here we are here we are bad internet
that's why I haven't been streaming for
a while but you can now get I want you
guys on the live stream to find out
first you can now get this brand new
merch which I'm clearly doing a good job
displaying let me do it better it's a
hoodie
it's a hoodie everybody got a new hoodie
it's got PTP on it very cool look at
that who doesn't like pink on black
nothing says I am a man like pink and
black if that's what you want to say how
are you all doing by the way see y'all
pumping in the chat on the back we have
even cooler 50 male club baby tell me
that isn't cool tell me that isn't
drugged dope very nice
check out represent calm slice cutie pie
put a pad to get that for that lit merch
fam a very nice have we sold a single
one yet let me scroll down to see I
can't I can't see anything
great well this has been great hahaha
it's really cool I really like the merch
I'm glad I can have merch I'm actually
happy with chips worldwide
portion of the profits will go to save
the children it's a great charity I
would be supported them in the past and
know it's just a cool thing I'm very
nice I'm a little sick I'm sorry it's so
disgusting let's see what you guys are
saying I like you and your merch blue
athletic thank you very much I like you
and I don't know about your March but
you know slow mode isn't on it should be
on but maybe it's not I think it's just
so many people riding that it seems like
it isn't it's the merge selling like a
god Church I can't confirm but I will
I'm yes I'm gonna go with yes oh I don't
have the money that's okay I wish I
could give out some for free that'd be
dope imma come from Taiwan
oh that's cool I'm come from Sweden
that's great that's great it's God
Church level yes yes it is these are
great questions by the way
Dino content cop last part was the best
when you showed up I'm glad you guys
enjoy that I'm really glad Ian day bruh
the guy who produced the music
it's from UK so I got a chance to be
part of the that little bit I got there
sort of penguin my Wayne it's really
weird I didn't really heard the song
before so I didn't know the vibe I
didn't realize how awkward it because I
didn't have a verse I just had to like I
guess I'm dancing in the back I just
started doing [ __ ] old school dance
moves it was fun it was super fun it's
probably the most fun shoots I've ever
done just because we were just [ __ ]
about it
guten tag meine Freunde guten tag to you
Anton right back at you let's see what
you guys are saying about the merge poor
connection that's great G disel why do
you always have to troll me with the
comments dude hello from Africa that's
great that's great
I'm not gonna read the rest though how
did you find the old s music I just
looked at jazz on bandicam bandicam is
that what it's called Bandcamp bandicam
is what I record with dude show me the
merch okay well let's go through the
merch let's go through it give me one
second you actually make good mic well
I'm glad you got a represent as good
designers they got really good designers
but it took a while to get the right
design we didn't get it right away I'm
glad I'm glad I said no to a couple so
that we got to where we got this dope as
merch man
let's create a new scene display capture
got a close all my pron alright this
will do you see me right now right oh
they're close spotify shizzle sorry guys
that's actually what you care about
right now isn't it okay alright so i
someone donate it i guess i don't know
what just happened here we go look at
that beautiful Swedish Viking look at
that look at that beautiful face Oh
video output low oh no Hillary Clinton I
have no idea with axe coming from the
stream just finished itself that's great
streaming resumed great the stream dying
this is this is my life you know this is
how you gotta live it when you have
great internet like the great PewDiePie
this is how you got a deal with it
good lag thank you
can you see me now what is happening
recipes stream and might see you doing
something Mars yet please I always tell
her like what do you know and she's I
have anything then I beat her sorry
those dumb joke okay
is it working I got a yellow no now in
red as soon as I said it it's on red
okay well anyway this is the merch all
right and this is the back of the merch
very cool
the colors looks great I'm very happy
with it I'm very proud of it I would go
with a bigger size actually now that I
see it's a little small on me but this
is my personal preference part of the
proceeds will go to save the children
from all the merch you can also get the
t-shirt if you feel like that's your
thing
ship worldwide what else can I say you
know what I'm gonna buy we have sizes 5
Excel if you're extra Foofa I have we
got from the last one if you're extra
food but we can just add in more how
many should I get worst dream ever thank
you the stream just finished I know I
this is what happens when you pewdiepie
so if you want to buy a fifty likeness I
can't believe how bad it is how is it
this bad my bit red it has six hundred
I'll put it on five hundred maybe that
will do the trick you know to me it's
incredible I can't even stream my 360
rice gum made its response I don't know
if you guys have seen it
it's pretty good
we knew rice gum could actually rap I
can't even [ __ ] stream a song
incredible incredible well that was that
was me announcing my March everyone I
did it good job
good job me is it offline again are you
kidding me alright well I did it I don't
know what today I don't know what today
I thought it would work i streamed here
before and it was fine alright well that
was that I'll see you guys when I have
internet they told me they would give me
an update this week so we'll see how
that goes
sorry I don't know what to do I thought
it would work bye